what did you make it the last series did
you watch much I was confused there's an
actor you often have to spend expend a
lot of energy trying to make a silk
purse out of a pig's ear and improve bad
writing but it's a peculiar business
because there's probably a case for
writing two versions of a draft one for
actors and one for potential find
answers because potential finances often
by and large tend to be short on
imagination and you really have to spell
it out as I understand you were you you
were killed on the toilet - by a member
of courage yes by my ungrateful what
would you say to him if you could have a
word in his ear now you pompous prat he
was so wrong you were ruthlessly and
somewhat humiliating killed off by our
son weren't you on the news grateful
little stuff I mean after all I've done
for it never more ruthless than when
he's dealing with his least-favorite son
can you talk a little bit about working
with this is a very very bright very
smart Godzilla my lord
hopes are not tigh ring will just red
wedding amore yes he would thank you
very much and you bring a majesty you
bring a presence which a lot of actors
don't have you are a class act basically
and a lot of it I think how many much
the first one was was in a tent it was
in a tent that was in a field in here
o'clock in the morning yes bitterly cold
and I thought why are we in this tent
there are no shots outside the tent this
tent could be set up on the studio floor
and we could all be warm instead of
freezing our asses off in the middle of
this field 20 miles outside of Belfast
welcome welcome to Game of Thrones he's
fighting for us
Godzilla I totally agree he is he's not
fighting against us he's fighting for us
because he knows how valuable this
it is Lord bakken Bay excuse me
my daughter father used to recount that
when they arrived in Broadstairs the
word went round look out the dance boys
have arrived there was a time I was a
romantic leading man Pettersson it's got
to changed a bit but I was arrested for
unruly behavior I'm likely to cause a
beach at the peace section five of the
Public Order Act 1936 said bad guys are
often posh old and British so uh did he
deliberately tick all three boxes I am
NOT posh I'm not as young as I was and I
am British people a lot of people have
described in was a being a bad guy I
don't I didn't actually see him with a
bad guy he's strong he's enigmatic and
he doesn't smile very much but compared
to quite a lot of other people in this
story he's he's he's quite a good guy
really and I we have Harvey Weinstein
behind us
couldn't be better really